numéro 3009 ce bel y ait la tête rose et
au gigot bien rebondi et aux avants
éclaté est une des fiertés de françois
bernard cet éleveur a remporté cinq prix
de conformation des bêtes et de qualité
de l'aisne un véritable plébiscite pour
le seul sélectionneur en race charmoise
de la région centre val de loire
elle a été créée pour ses remarquables
qualités d'adaptation aux terrains
pauvres une très forte une très bonne
qualité de viande une très bonne qualité
de l'aisne également parce que il faut
savoir que dans la charmoise il ya de la
sologne hot du kent du dif l'est et du
mérinos qui apporte la qualité de
l'aisne et le kent si vous voulez ça
amène l'excellente qualité de viande et
l'aptitude à s'habituer aux pâturages
pauvres étaient bien là et pis la stap
couché par bouger et pis le border
collie veille au grain pas question de
laisser filer le trésor dont la
notoriété et la cote ont sensiblement
augmenté ces derniers jours niveau
commandes fermes si vous voulez ça va
être dans les 15 jours trois semaines à
venir entre 150 et 250 bateaux en plein
soleil
1200 ovins composent ce cheptel sur 155
ha
ces récompenses sont également une
aubaine pour développer la vente des
plats cuisinés tâche qui incombe à l'un
de ses fils on va se permettre de mettre
tout simplement à logo avec le prix et
gagnez un sur nos plats cuisinés
nos idées pour booster la vente mettre
en avant un argument supplémentaire pour
mettre en confiance une fois de plus le
consommateur parce qu'on est des
professionnels on le démontre encore au
salon de l'agriculture cette année donc
c'est pour nous c'est très important
prochain objectif parvenir à conserver
cette qualité reconnue dans tout
l'hexagone
car s'il n'est pas facile de parvenir à
ce niveau il est encore plus difficile
de rester le numéro